cool all right guys my name is Brian
lagunes and I came all the way from
Boise Idaho who knows where Boise Idaho
is you know where Boise isid it is an
Idaho so Idaho is on the west coast uh
people know where California is it's one
of our neighbors we actually have six
neighbors plus Canada so we're actually
a pretty big state but we only have a
million people in the entire state but I
like it it's small it's a little big
city right uh and today I'm here to talk
to you about building crossplatform
games with unity now this is an intro
talk this is basically you've never even
thought about building games or you're
interested and you've never cracked open
Unity uh so that's that's the target for
this talk should be fun we're going to
actually build a game from scratch to
see how easy it is and normally I don't
say this because I don't want people to
feel bad but my six-year-old daughter
uses this to build games so just so you
know it's not that hard right uh I'm a
product manager for a company called
infragistics anyone ever heard of
infragistics we actually used to have a
little office here but uh we shut it
down for some reason probably too
expensive food here is crazy expensive
guys gez uh but I manage all the examl
products WPF what used to be silver
light wwp zamon form zamon iOS Amon
Android native Android native iOS I'm
responsible for all that stuff
uh if you guys want to contact me Bel
lagonis infra justice.com hit me up on
my blog and then uh Twitter Brian lagona
so you can like tweet how awesome this
session is right and if it sucks just my
name's Scott Hanselman
so you know so you just put that in
there this sucks
Hanselman right um I'm also the owner
and manager of the prism project you
guys ever heard of prism so that's
that's my baby and actually Zam forms
2.3.1 just went stable so I'm going to
release a new stable version of prism
probably tonight all right so enough
about that let's talk about what we're
going to do today we're going to talk
about all this stuff we're going to talk
about what Unity is we're going to go
over the ID we're going to create a
scene make a Terrain and then we're
going do some scripting and we're going
to have a fully functional game at the
end of this right from scratch file new
my favorite and then we'll deploy if we
have time which I'm sure we will so
you're like hey what's Unity oh I know
what Unity is it's that dependency
injection container I use it all the
time with prism it's so awesome no
that's not it this is a different Unity
this is Unity 3D right so this is a IDE
for building 2D and 3D games okay it's
an editor and a player which means not
only do you create the game inside of
this editor but you can actually play it
as you create it which is really cool
and this multiplatform so no matter what
platform you want to hit you could
Target it Windows phone wait Windows
Phone
anybody
really wow I'm
surprised uh Xbox
PlayStation
Blackberry okay I didn't think about
black okay Blackberry uh we you get the
idea iOS Android uh basically the idea
is you write once and you just kind of
change your target make some
modifications for the device and deploy
again it's a beautiful
thing so some really popular games that
have been built with unity Call of Duty
Strike Team drift Mania Temple Run
everyone knows Temple Run right no who
doesn't know Temple Run if you got kids
you know this game Subway Surfers
another one if you have kids you know
that game right so Unity is not just
like this hobbyist type thing I mean
companies big companies use Unity to
build Real Deal games okay that they
charge a lot of money for okay so we're
going to get out of slides and
essentially like I said we're going to
go file new and we're going to create a
game from
scratch all right we're done with slides
for the day all right so the first thing
you need to know is where to get
Unity you need to go to unity3d.com
okay then just click on the get Unity
link right top right corner and there's
this cool little free version called
personal download that one it's free
it's beautiful you can do everything you
want just about everything you need to
do for your games okay so once you have
Unity it's going to install it you're
going to have a nice little icon up here
just double click that and it's going to
launch Unity you get this little
dialogue that says hey what kind of
project do you want to do do you want to
open an existing one or let's go ahead
and create a new one so we'll create a
new one and uh we'll call this uh
NDC Sid okay now as you can see I can
choose from a 2d game or a 3D game I'm
gonna pick 3D because I think that's
cooler right and then don't we don't
care about adding asset Pat packages now
and actually when you create games you
won't even add these now and then I
don't care about analytics in this demo
so we'll go ahead and create the project
and this is actually relatively quick
now I will warn you I just downloaded
the brand new version last night right
from the
website so we'll see if they changed
anything I did that one time and they
made a breaking change they had a bug
and it was fun doing realtime
debugging okay so this is Unity this is
your ID it's actually built on top of
mono develop so as you create your game
you're actually building on top of mono
just so you know okay you have a couple
of panes by default there's more to it
but we're going to keep it simple today
we have our scene view now your scene
view this is three-dimensional space
this is where you're going to be
interacting with your objects okay so
for example if I wanted to add a cube
into
here here's our cube right now we're in
3D space so we have three axes X
YN great Z is her depth so that means we
have these cool little tools we can use
to manipulate these objects in this
threedimensional space we can
rotate right we can
scale different ways of scaling and of
course we have other cool tools for
scaling and moving things
around now I will say you have to be
careful when you're dragging things
around in this space because you're in
three-dimensional space this can play
tricks on your eyes so you think you're
like Center screen but you're like
600,000 kmers below your view right it
gets crazy
now this
here is your hierarchy this represents
all the objects in your
scene
okay over here we have your inspector
now your inspector is essentially a
property get in Visual Studio you select
the object and then all the properties
and values you can manipulate show up in
the inspector now I want to make a note
here everything in here is essentially a
script also referred to as a component
but it's really just a script behind the
scenes and we're going to create our own
uh later
on then you have your project
pan this is all the assets and all the
files and everything that makes up your
game as it exists on disk okay so if I
were to come in
here and create a new folder say
scenes and let's go ahead and save this
scene it's like main
whoops main scene we'll stick it in that
folder now I will rightclick show and
explore that is my main scene I just
created so everything that exists here
will be on your hard drive okay and then
we have this game
view the game View view this is where
you actually manipulate and play your
game right so you do all this
manipulation up here blah blah build my
game I hit play and this becomes active
and now you see your play you play the
game with the keyboard or mouse or
whatever real time right here
now I'm going to show you a little trick
a little tip I learned the hard way so
let's say I hit play now of course while
we have as a cube it doesn't do anything
uh so let's let me just rotate this
right
quick
okay so let's say I'm in play mode uh
and then you know it's like okay I got
to make some changes so I'm going to
come in here and I'm going to make some
changes do some cool
things right whatever I we'll rotate
this one let's say we
spend no hour or two just playing with
stuff got my game right where I want it
and I noticed oh man I'm in play mode
let me stop
this
no oh man I just lost like two hours of
work because I didn't realize I was in
play mode when you were in play mode
anything you do is basically temporary
and the second you exit play mode lost
okay so the first thing you do when you
install Unity make a note of this you
want to go to
edit
preferences colors you see this play
mode tint change that to like an ugly
ugly color like
red now I know I'm in play mode and any
change I make will be lost okay so do
that because you do not want to go
through what I went through when I first
did that
okay any questions so
far no all right so let's start building
a game I thought we would create this
little island we'll throw some treasure
chests on on it and we'll go look for
them dig them up you know collect the
treasure get points and win the game so
in order to do that we need to build a
Terrain okay now I want to step back
just a little bit and you remember when
I saved this scene I called it main
scene a scene is essentially a level
think of a scene as a level so we're
dealing with a level and we just named
it main scene so I'm going to build
level one if you will okay so I can go
into this create
and I'm going to create some 3D objects
and right down here we have a Terrain
object so I'm just going to select
terrain and I know it doesn't look big
but this thing is massive it just added
a very massive terrain object into my
scene okay so we're going to leave it
right where it's at it's positioned 00 0
exactly where we want it center of our
world okay now I'm going to start
manipulating this terrain I want to add
mountains and trees and grass and water
water so the first thing I'm going to
start is with my mountains what I want
to do is I have a nice little terrain
menu set here where I can do things to
this terrain like I can you know raise
up my terrain mountains I can paint it
trees grass right we do all this cool
stuff so all I'm going to do is I'm
going to select I'm going to raise the
terrain I can pick my brush set
different settings but we'll just keep
everything default for now and we just
to come here and do paint paint paint
paint paint right there make a little
coat right so I'm just going to paint
some mountains back
here nothing too
fancy all right so we have some
mountains
cool but they're kind of ugly right
they're real ugly the gray what we want
to do is we want to add a texture to
these okay we we want them to to look
like something so in order to do that we
need to have what's called an asset
right now an asset essentially
it could be a model it could be uh a
texture like we're about to do it could
be a script it could be anything what we
want is textures so where do we get
these assets well there's a couple ways
to do it the easiest way and the fastest
is actually go to unity3d.com and go to
the asset store right here top rightand
corner there are so many free or pay if
you want to pay but there's tons of free
assets that you can download and bring
right into your game
uh so for example if you want a zombie
uh just search for zombie I want
free right and then uh here's a zombie
character I can click on that bring it
into my game and use it free of charge
and as you can see we have models
scripts particle systems textures you
name it you can get
it now always go to the website because
although if you go to window there's an
asset store window this is so slow and
frustrating don't even bother don't even
bother coming here just go to the
website so much easier so along those
lines another thing I want to mention is
that Unity is not meant to build assets
okay you're not building 3D models in
this you're consuming 3D models if you
want to build a model you'll use
something like blender Maya 3D Studio
Max uh Maya and 3D Studio Max are really
expensive uh even if you have a student
discount I think it's like a couple
Grand uh but blender is free the UI
sucks but it's free and you can build
whatever you want there's lots of free
models out there but essentially you
build your models in another program and
then you bring them in to Unity and
compose your game from those objects
okay
now Unity ships with some builtin asset
packages I'm going to bring in the
environment package because that's where
uh like trees and grass and we have some
textures that exist already so you can
come in here and take
everything but we probably don't want to
do that we'll just take the uh
environment section and
import and then this one's pretty small
so it should come in relatively
quickly okay that's pretty slow
actually actually I'm kind of running
low on uh on RAM too and space I got so
much stuff on this computer it's time
for the uh the six-month Windows
wipe we all have to do that right every
six months up time to wipe Windows
reload wow that's really
slow any questions so
far yeah if you go in there if you go go
to the store some of them actually have
the
licenses unity3d.com
let's just find one right
quick we'll go back to our
zombie let's just click on
him it's free model
textures we can scroll down here see if
he includes any type of licensing
information
I don't see anything that stands out at
me on this
one Publishers
website if there's a license normally
it's included in the in the
package we're can look down here see if
they noted
it yep no license required on this
one all right
so we've downloaded our assets here we
go environment
perfect now what we want to do is we're
going to paint this mountain range so
I'm going to come to this
paintbrush I'm going to edit textures
and add a new texture and I really hate
this user interface because it really
makes no sense
sometimes then I'm going to select a
texture uh how about this one add it
boom okay it's not that great right but
it's something so we'll go ahead and
zoom on in and we can see that we have
sand well Sand's cool and all but those
really aren't mountains what I'd really
like to have is some like Rocky texture
on the mountain so let's add another
texture uh this one looks good make sure
you select
it right there and then you can just
paint right on the
mountains if you can tell I make noises
when I paint and when I create things
I'm just like right all right so I know
this looks like
crap but if you zoom
in
there we go you can start to see that
the texture starts to come through okay
so Unity the IDE does some tricks to
keep your IDE responsive uh as you zoom
out it shows way less detail uh
otherwise if it's showing a lot of
detail all the time your system's just
going to come to a halt or you'll need
just this massive Mainframe type
computer to run it so as you zoom out
you'll lose detail as you zoom in you'll
get more detail keep keep that in mind
I'm going to show you another gotcha
later okay so we've painted our mountain
range uh how about we add some some
trees so I'm going to go ahead and click
the little tree
button edit trees add one and this is
another weird thing like oh well I got
to assign a tree so how about
uh how about this palm tree that looks
good all right so now let's bring the
brush size down a little
bit pow pow pow we got trees
right zoom in on them whoops too
far
beautiful okay we got some palm trees
got some sand mountain
range uh let's add some grass right so
I'm going to click this thing that looks
like
flowers edit add grass
texture now all these textures that I'm
using they came from the environment
package we
imported uh let's just pick something
down here
uh this one will
work okay so now I'm going to paint some
grass paint paint paint paint paint
paint uh
oh oh oh hold on I think it's
broken rage paint okay something's not
working let me see what's going oh my
God look at all that grass I just threw
in my
view right remember that thing I was
telling you about detail and when you're
zoomed out you don't get a lot of detail
but as you zoom in you'll show you the
detail so when you're zoomed way out and
you you're like man I just want on this
grassp oh it's not working and you rage
paint yeah don't do that I did that and
like my entire scene just had grass all
over it uh because I didn't realize when
I was getting started about the little
trick so be very careful when you start
doing finer detailed paintings or grass
or uh creating objects in your games
because as you can see there's no grass
you zoom in there's a a lot of grass
because I I rage painted but there is
control Z so you can just undo that if
you
want see undone we'll just put a little
patch here and a little patch there and
one right there looks good okay next we
need water cuz I want an oasis so
luckily in our environment package we
got water too so I'm going to go ahead
and select this water basic day light
now I want to make a note your first
instinct is when you get this model you
want to drag it and drop it right into
your scene like that don't get into that
habit while it might work sometimes most
of the time it won't because while you
think you're dropping it flat you're
actually dropping it either 600,000
kilometers above it or below it and you
won't know it until you start zooming in
it's like where's my water Where's My
object so what I like to do is I'll drag
it right into the
hierarchy that will put it right there
00 0 and then I can just drag it where I
want
it and see even then I didn't drag right
so it like drug it way down I'm not even
level anymore I'm minus 104 meters you
see
that okay I got to get it right on the
green there we go it's a little small so
let's go ahead and scale it up not
rotate
scale
do
this now right now our water is
perfectly on zero so it's it's basically
running into our ground as you can see
it's like just kind of weird it's
intersecting right so what we'll want to
do is we'll want to bring that up on the
Y just a hair just to like a 01 just to
raise it up just a tad so we can see it
all right now not what you're thinking
like wow we're doing all this designing
up here but what the heck's going on
here this is our game view this is what
we're supposed to see when we play our
game well when I created this scene this
camera was added by default we just
never took the time to come in here and
move it so let's go ahead and grab the
camera right and we'll just move it we
got to turn
it you see that little cone around the
camera this little outline that shows
your fi of view on the
camera so we'll go ahead and move this
around move it
up all right doesn't have to be perfect
we're gonna not use this in a minute
anyways okay great so and of course if I
play this nothing's really going to
happen uh and right now it's hard to see
but the water is moving the grass is
moving right you get all that for free
from
Unity but let's make this cooler all
right so I think we're we're good on the
level I'm going to call that good for
now uh now what we need is we need that
person running around exploring finding
treasure chest so we need a firsters
character well great well I can create
one myself get one from the asset store
or I can just use the characters package
that comes with
unity and and we'll just import
everything I don't want to go through
and
select uh so like I
said Unity ships with a default
characters package comes with like a
first person a third person we're going
to use the first person uh you can go to
the asset store get characters doesn't
matter uh totally up to you build your
own wouldn't recommend that because
there's a lot that goes into it because
you got to worry about jumping and
firing and you know going left going
right you have to script all the
movement and these ship with all the
scripts necessary for
that all right so let's go into
characters first
person and we'll go with this FPS
controller we'll do that
one all right automatically my camera
changed again well this first person has
its own camera on it so now we're going
to drag this first person
around we'll stick them in the water or
her right and we'll rotate around
and we'll bring it up just a
tad now it'll work and that means I can
delete this other camera because we
don't need it anymore all right so now
I'm going to play the
game oh mouse works right I can jump I
got
footsteps I'm
running I'm in this beautiful grass just
flowing in the Wind
check out this water and this is the
basic water there's more you know
there's better quality water as well
that just looks super real all right
that's cool right we have to code
anything we're just kind of clicking and
dragging around right no no code yet but
we have a firsters exploring a level
that we created and uh we didn't have to
write any code for it all right uh but
you know right now it's uh it's kind of
boring when I play a first person person
game I like that music that that
motivates you you know gets you wanting
to go look for stuff
so I have a sound
package that I'm going to bring
in and we're going to add some uh sound
some music to our scene
here all right let's go
sounds let's see let's listen to
these n it's not that's not very
motivating about this
one nah it's not that good
either that's not
bad there you go oh yeah not in the head
we got it that's the one that's the one
we'll use that
one all right so I'm going to come over
to my first person character I'm going
to add a component which which I said is
just a script we'll call it an audio
Source right down here and then we have
this little
uh clip audio clip we're just going to
click and drag that onto the audio clip
and loop it now we play our
game all right I'm motivated let's go
find some
treasure oh ran into a tree so you
notice that the trees have Collision
detection built right into them we
collide with them
can I climb this mountain is it too
steep a little steep let me
jump cool all
right any questions so
far okay so doing underwater you'll do a
little some special tricks but it's not
hard so when you're building a game you
got to kind of think outside the box
you'll have your top level water that's
highly reflective and looks really cool
right but then you'll build another you
know another element that represents
your underwater maybe it's just kind of
hazy and foggy and you have bubbles
floating through it or something like
that right uh but you build
everything all right let's see so we got
uh we got our character we got some
sound we need uh we need some treasure
and I got just the object got a little
treasure
box bring that
in
all right so let's go ahead and drag my
treasure box up to my
hierarchy and we'll bring it in
right there okay another trick this is a
very simple scene but when you get a lot
of objects in
here you're going to want to be able to
like find that and it may be small like
tiny tiny small so the best way to do
that is in your hierarchy select the
object move your mouse over your scene
and hit the F button button and it will
zoom in on that object okay that's the
easiest way to find something all right
so we have our treasure box so I've
dropped it in there so I should be able
to just play the game and run right into
it right and just let's
go Ah that's no fun all right we don't
get any more freebies okay we actually
got to write a little bit of code now
but it's not complicated at all
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to write a script but before we get
that we have to talk about exactly how
this is going to work because we got to
start solving problems in unity now game
problems which is going to be different
than if you were building a line of
business application right so we got to
start thinking okay what's got to happen
what's got to happen is when I run into
this box it's got to disappear and I got
to get points for it so let's start with
the first problem running into the box
how do I know when I run into the box so
I can execute code well in unity we have
this thing called a
collider and we happen to have a couple
different shapes and one of those shapes
is a box collider right in the Box
collider if I zoom in you can see this
little green outline that's my collider
that I just added to this box now if you
have a different shaped object just pick
the shape that's closest to your object
and then manipulate the the collider to
fit as best as you can now so we have a
Collider but that just means I'm going
to run into it well I don't want to just
run into it I need a notification I need
to know when I run into it so there's a
little checkbox here for is trigger make
sure you click is trigger when that
happens we will be
notified our script can respond to that
o I ran into something let's run some
code okay great so let's go ahead and
start doing some
coding now I'm a little add so I got to
oh CD I got to put a a scripts folder in
here now you can create your scripts a
couple different ways C so where's my C
devs okay and
JavaScript okay well I'm C so we'll do c
but if you're more comfortable with
JavaScript you can write them in
JavaScript no problem all right so we'll
call this a chest
pickup and then I'm just going to open
this
up
and as you can see it's going to use
Visual Studio as my editor so we get
debugging and all that great stuff we
can hit break points debug our game it's
it's a beautiful
thing okay so scripts will derive from
what's called a mono behavior and it's
going to stub out two methods for you
start and update start think of it as
almost like a Constructor it's going to
execute once when the object is created
okay so you're going to put your setup
code in there and then update
is going to be called every time every
frame okay so if you're running 30
frames per second that code is being
called 30 times a second so don't be
connecting to databases and doing crazy
stuff in there okay that just I've seen
it I have performance problems in my
game what's going on yeah with the
opening and closing Connections in a in
an update so we won't be using
that now you remember we added that that
is trigger check well
I know because I read the
docs that in order to respond to that I
need to add a method called on trigger
enter and collider and it takes a
collider
okay I'm G to show you somewhere you're
going to spend a lot of time unity3d.com
uh
learn documentation
you're going to spend a lot of time in
here because there's a lot of like
hidden things like that method like the
only way you know to do that is if you
come in here like how in the heck do I
respond to a collision and they'll say
oh just add a method called on trigger
entered and you're good okay great
yeah I believe it does yes but it's
actually really it's quick I mean you
don't even know
right okay so on trigger enter so we
have this
collider all right so what we're going
to say we're going to say hey if the
collider do game object. tag
equals player then we're going to
destroy game
object whoa whoa whoa what what did you
just say okay let me
explain so the collider that's what
we're running into
okay so the Collider has a game object
this is the object colliding with with
the collider so if that tag equal player
then we're going to destroy game object
now this game object is the game object
that this script is going to be attached
to which is the chest so we're going to
destroy the chest but what about this
part how do we how do we know this well
we got to tell it so let's go back to
our
game in unity and I'm going to select
our person here our little first person
now right here in the top right hand
corner we have what's called a tag
you'll use this this concept A Lot
building games now there are a couple
standard tags in unity respawn finish
editor only main camera player game
controller player right there you can
create your own tags which you will but
for our purposes we're going to use the
player tag now we know whenever this
player runs into this Collider
that tag we're going to know the tag
it's going to be tagged player so we
know okay we're a player we ran into
this let's destroy we're not quite done
yet though all we do is write the script
now what we want to do is we want to
apply the script to the treasure box
well that's very difficult to do so let
me just go ahead and do it for you
done all you have to do click drag drop
you have applied the script okay so now
if I coded everything up right and the
demo gods are with
Meo there we go
right okay that's cool that's cool that
was not very difficult but I you notice
I had to make the Boop sound
myself and I I don't expect people
playing my game to go Boop every time
they pick something up so I need a sound
I need something that gives me that
validation that I got something you know
like oh oh did I get that let me go back
look for it oh where'd it go did I get
it right we don't want that experience
we want to know yeah we got that so we
want to play a sound clip when that
treasure chest is picked up so let's go
back to our script so we know we got to
pick up a sound clip so let's go ahead
and add a property uh of type audio
clip and we'll call it a pickup
clip and then in here we'll just
say audio
Source
dot play clip at
point we'll use our pickup clip and then
the position this is important
transform.
position now in
unity sound depends on Space spatial
sound essentially so imagine you have
this great scene and you have a
waterfall in that scene okay and this is
the waterfall our screen is the
waterfall so my character walks up to it
and it's walking this way and the
waterfall is on the right the sound is
coming from the right speakers in my 7.1
surround sound because that's how I play
games right and if my character turns
around now the sound comes out of the
leftand speakers and as the character
gets further away from the sound it gets
quieter as you get closer it gets louder
right so we want to say that we're going
to play this sound at the location of
the chest so the transform this is the
property off the the object the script's
attached to and the position of it right
so where this chest is play that sound
because you don't want to Bing and then
have it coming off in your right-and
speakers like what the heck did I do
right
okay so now let's go to our treasure box
we're going to select
it let's collapse this now we can see in
our chest pickup we have a new property
pick pick up
clip all I'm going to do I already have
a sound I I already took the time
scoured the internet looking for the
perfect
sound I do not think you'll be
disappointed here we
go beautiful I'm validated I got points
right any questions so
far sorry I forgot about the mic thing
do I really need a mic I just want to
ask the destroy bit that you said
destroy game object game object is
actual player no game object is the
chest right and the collider is is the
player yes the the object colliding the
game object right here colliding with
the collider is the player we're tagged
it so if we go back
to and select our player we tagged it
player right
here and then our script on the collider
itself remember that bot collider we
added that's this
collider we're going to say what's the
game object that ran into me oh you're
the player gotcha so let's go ahead and
destroy the
chest yes
this well almost we don't want to say
this specifically because that's the
actual script right that's the the chest
pickup script itself that's the script
object this is the game object the
script attached to
right
okay close that actually we're done with
that person know something like this
sorry uh so if like U we have box and um
the car Collide and let's say player
Collide so would it handle yeah you just
tell it you just got but like tag on one
or well it depends on your scenario you
can Tang them all the same you can say
they everything's a player bad guy good
guy doesn't matter it's a player or you
can say bad guys are enemies and this
guy over here he's player and you'll
just code if right here if player or bad
guy right you would check before you
destroy but is re related to uh the
person colliding right so I thought like
to the object colliding yeah you can tag
any object any object can have a tag so
anything that's tagged anything like you
can say enemy player or enemy or you
know super bad guy whatever all right or
bullet that's another one when you shoot
Angel is a bullet colliding with me then
I'm going to die right kind of thing
okay so we have a treasure chest we have
some
sound uh that's cool what else well I
think I want more than one Treasure
Chest personally I mean you know you
can't just have one uh so when you're
thinking about you know what I'm going
to make more than this your first
instinct is just to select copy paste
you move it right copy paste you move it
let's say you copy a whole bunch of
these objects let's say you have 100 of
them whatever and then you realize oh
man you know what I really wish this was
a little bigger so I'm just going to
make that
bigger oh crap I have 99 more of these I
have to go and make bigger that's going
to really suck well we don't want to do
that we want to make it easy on
ourselves right so there another concept
that you'll use all the time and we've
been using just may may not have noticed
so what's called a prefab so essentially
we're going to make a template out of
that treasure chest okay so I created a
new folder called
prefabs and all I'm going to do oh
what's this go ahead and delete that I'm
GNA take this treasure box I'm going
click and drag it into my prefabs folder
it is now a template just like that
right so what's that mean that means now
when I come in here and copy and paste
this bad
boy let me just move it over the side
let me zoom out a little
bit I'll move this one out to the side
all right now let's say I want to make a
change I want to make this these all
bigger
okay and there's a thousand of them well
now we have a new option in our
inspector under
prefab select revert
apply so I make my changes and now I'm
just going to go ahead and apply them
boom to all of them automatically right
so whenever I update the template
everything else I can apply to directly
awesome timesaver you'll use that all
the
time yeah that's that's the standard so
if we come in like for example standard
assets uh we'll go like
let's go down
to environment water see everything's
prefabs that's that's the that's the
convention all right
so now what's cool about that is even
though I've copied and pasted and all
that stuff because it's a
prefab they all work the same and
anytime I update that script or add
functionality or do anything to that
prefab everything else gets it now I
know the question your mind but Brian I
don't want to be copying and pasting a
100 thousand of those I'd rather just
programmatically create them and kind of
have them just appear and like spawn
them you can do that it's just code
you'll just write uh uh either a
particle system or a spawner right
because actually I don't know if you
noticed but if we come up
to a tag respawn right I mean spawn is a
concept that's used a lot in games so
you will programmatically create these
but you will use the prefab when you
create the object that way any change
you make to the prefab everything gets
it even when you're dynamically creating
them okay so we have our Treasure Chest
we have some cool music that's
motivating us we're picking them up uh
we need to keep score we need a score so
let's do
score okay so tracking scores fun and
challenging to say the least you really
have to kind of think outside the box
like okay how in the heck am I going to
keep track of score or stats or whatever
it's going to be across the game well
one approach is to use what's called a
game controller so we're going to go
ahead and create an empty game object
and I'm going to call it game
controller and this is such a common
approach it has a built-in tag called
game
controller right so we tagged it game
controller great so this empty object
it's it's not a physical object that's
in your scene that you can see it's more
of a uh think of it as like a
Singleton right you have this object
that's in your app and you're G to
access State off of it you can you can
kind of think of it like that so I have
this object I've added to my my game and
I'm going to use it to track state
perfect okay so I'm gonna add another
script and I'm gonna call it player
stats because I need to track
information about our player basically
how many points we're
getting so's go ahead and open
this let's see we will not be using
update at all we probably won't even
start but we'll start here
okay so I'm going to go
with a
score and then we need a public void
update score into value should
work and then all we're going to do is
say score plus equals
value
simple
okay now once we have that we're going
to say that this game controller is
going to be responsible for maintaining
player stats so we're going to take the
player stats and we're going to drag it
on to our game
controller and we can see we have our
score property here just like we set
right set at zero
okay well now that we have this this
object that's going to maintain this
state how in the heck do we access
this in in our other scripts like we got
to think about this okay so what's
happening is I'mma collide with the
chest I'm pick it up I'm going play a
sound it's going to be destroyed that's
probably where I want to add one or add
whatever to my score so that means I'm
in the I'm in the the chest pickup
script I'm here
now so I need to in
here we need to update the score before
we destroy the object right this is
where we're at now it's like okay how do
we get to that well because we're using
that game
object right we can access anything from
that now for let me let me just put
something here let's say
uh I got player stats stats so we need
the
object and I'm going to say VAR
controller game
object. get oh find sorry find object
with tag and what did we tag
it game
controller we got the game controller we
have the controller awesome so
now I can say stats equals controller
whoops not constant
force controller dot get component of
T now remember everything's a component
but it's really a script right they call
it component we want the player stats
script or component if you
will perfect we have the stats so what
that means is I can come in
here and go update score we'll add
one
okay make sure everything looks good
okay let's go ahead and go pick up
subscripts and let's watch the score
property as I pick up these
chests woo it
worked
perfect
okay any questions there did that look
confusing do I need to clarify just one
more
time okay one more time
so what we did is we created a game
controller which is an object that
exists in our game but it's not a
physical object it's just a state
manager if you will okay
we wrote a script that keeps track of
player stats it's like person equals new
person in a in an application right so
we just created an instance of that we
put an instance of that player stats
script on that state manager that game
controller okay now that means we needed
to access that
information from the chest pickup
script so
so instead of calling like in a in an
application that you write if you had
some type of State manager you would
probably it would probably be a static
method call like State manager. player
stats. score equals right well we don't
do that here instead we get that state
manager or that game
controller using Game object. find game
object with tag and it's tagged game
controller so if we go back to Unity
there's our game controller tag that we
tagged it okay so now that we have the
controller now we can get the player
stats object off of it using get
component that gives us access to that
player stats uh
information and then we just call the
update score method that we added to the
player stats
here to just add to it every time
okay have
controllers two game controllers well
you'll have to do a little extra work
let's go back here there is
a find objects with tab which will
return a
collection right so if you have more
than one game controller you'll have to
figure out which one you care about but
you can get them all with this fine
objects with tag which we'll bring back
in a a
collection okay so now we have score
we're keeping track track of this
information as we pick up our chests now
we have to display this
information to
our player right the person playing the
game like yeah it's great we have a
property but we need to expose that we
need something like a heads up display
with Radars and bullets and health and
all that crazy stuff right well we don't
have time for the crazy one so we're
going to create a very simple one so
we're going to go ahead create a 3D
object and we're going to add you UI
object sorry we're going to create a UI
object we're going to add
text now when I add of this text notice
that it's automatically surrounded by a
canvas and right now you don't even see
it you're like Brian what are you
talking about I didn't see you add
anything well let me do my little F
trick so I'm gon to select the canvas
scroll my mouse over hit F now I'm going
to zoom out and I can see my canvas
now okay that's the canvas so now if I
select the text within
that you can see that it's down at the
very
bottom that means if I look at the very
bottom oh I can kind of see something
here now yeah so let's go ahead and move
that ah there we
go right and we'll make that uh zero how
about
24 and we that's we'll call it good for
now okay so essentially when you add the
UI object creates this canvas and it has
its own little camera and it basically
sticks it right on top of your game
right it just imposes it right on top
like a
layer this is how you create I mean you
can create anything you want there's
some very complex heads up displays you
can write uh and you can download them
free from the asset store Radars and all
that crazy stuff but this is essentially
what you do this is a simple version of
it
so now we're got to think okay I'm G to
update the score I got to update this
text where am I updating the score well
I'm updating the score in my player stat
script here okay so that means we need
to
add another property first we're going
to go using Unity engine.
UI because we
want a text
object now we can
say
two string perfect that looked easy well
it is so let's go to our game controller
we're going to see a new property score
text all we have to do is I'm going to
take the text object I want to update
click drag
assign now when we play our
game one there we go
two three
perfect easy right any
questions
No like is it track in unity I mean what
if you want to go back like 10 steps
because there's a lot of mocking around
with sounds and creating the scenes and
everything control Z it keeps going back
yeah it goes back so you can undo like I
can go ahead and hit control Z and it
will undo that text assignment
but control Z is your
friend okay so let's see I got six
minutes we can do I'm G let you guys
choose we can talk real briefly about
deployment or we can do another level
and load that level when we win the game
what do you guys want to
do deployment okay let's do deployment
so we win okay game over let's talk
about deployment first we want to go to
build
settings now scenes in build this is
important you're going to want to add
all the scenes you want included in your
game in this dialogue you can click and
drag them in or just add them one at a
time as they're open so I've added the
main scene now here's all the platforms
we can Target I'm on a Windows uh
machine so I'm going to go ahead and
select windows and go switch
platform boom I'm now going to deploy to
a Windows store app I want want it to be
a universal I want direct 3D local
machine and for debugging C
projects now here's a
gotcha Windows store
only the moment you change and you
switch this
platform you must come up to this menu
Mobile
input and disable
that if you do not do that your keyboard
will not work
and you'll say why isn't this working oh
my God it was working just a minute ago
what' I do and you're going to go
through all your scripts you're going to
rewrite your game and you're not going
to know you might even switch back to a
different platform and then it's going
to work but if you're on Windows store
make sure you disable mobile input or
your unless you expect to be hooked up
to a uh a phone or a uh a controller
okay so once you disable that then you
can go to player
settings now player settings this is
just basic basically your app manifest
information right setting your icon your
capabilities you know your uh
resolutions and stuff this is your at
manifest now I'm going to say this is
one time
only so you'll come in here you'll do
all your settings set your icons any
type of resolution stuff right Splash
images uh any of your capabilities
you'll select all these we're going to
go ahead and hit build we're going to go
ahead and add a new
folder I'll call it
build we'll select that we'll let this
run because this got to restore Nate
packages we know how slow that can be oh
wow that was actually quite
quick but this takes a while what's this
doing it's now building up visual studio
Solutions so we're going to be able to
open this game in visual studio hit F5
and debug it so that's what's going on
right now it's taking all our assets
bundling it all up doing doing
everything all the magic and it's going
to spit out a visual studio solution for
us and it's going to take all this
information and set it in our app
manifest so when I say this is one way
what I mean is when it creates that
Visual Studio solution and we open it up
if we go make changes to the app
manifest manually and then we decide oh
you know I need to come back into unity
and make some changes and I publish
again it will not overwrite
anything okay once you publish this one
time these settings it's one way it will
not happen again so you don't have to
worry about losing any customizations
you made inside Visual
Studio okay which is nice but it can be
confusing if you're depending because at
first when I was getting started I was
like I was updating this this was my
source this is what I was using and I'd
like make a change deploy it's like man
it's not updating what the heck so it
took me a while to figure out it only
does it once
yep you sure can
because design time designing it is not
the same as deploying it and also what's
cool is so for Windows store it's
creating Visual Studio
solution for Android it's going to
create the Android solution for iOS it's
going to do what the xcode project right
so depending on the platform it's going
to create the project for that
Target even for
iOS it will create the project on a
Windows machine of course you can't open
it and compile it and all that stuff uh
but it will actually create the project
files for you excuse
me yeah and then what's different about
the other platforms too is you see this
build and run that doesn't work with
Windows but for like IOS and Android you
can you can just if you're on a a Mac or
something you could hit build and run it
will do all this and run it
automatically but for uh for Windows it
won't work you have to go through Visual
Studio you have to build
actually well we're running out of time
this is taking longer than I was hoping
it would take
so uh let me close
this and then uh I think I
have yeah this demo right
here I'll just kind of show you right
quick because it's basically times
up so the first thing you'll have to do
because this isn't obvious either is
this is going to default to
arm and that's not going to work you'll
build and you're going to get build
failures like what's going on oh I'm
pissing me off right uh just change your
your platform here to x86 and then build
and then it will work but this is
essentially what you'll get when you uh
when this completes and then so you have
your app that'ss you have your package.
appx manifest uh you essentially build
it deploy it locally and then
uh let's see right
there and then when you run the app
because we're using the personal Edition
we're going to get a splash screen this
is personal edition if you want to pay
money that goes away and you can create
your own splash
screen and then this little 4 gigabyte
machine is struggling to process all
this and then there's our game right you
see the water everything
works
all
right where's my score oh there it is
this was a really quick thing I did last
night just to make sure it would work
yeah and then you win right but uh
that's my time I'm actually one minute
over sorry uh thanks for coming I
appreciate it I'm going to be here so
feel free to ask more questions uh as I
pack up and head out thanks guys I
appreciate
it